you may be surprised but the most
popular algorithm for finding motifs in
DNA sequences roll dice and take chances
to find such materials they're called
randomized algorithm how they work
we now learned how to construct profile
given my tips but can we construct my
tips given profile we can because given
an arbitrary profile and a set of
sequences DNA we can construct the set
of my teeths of profile and DNA but
simply finding profile most probable
k-mers in each sequence from DNA and
therefore we can further iterate this
process by finding profile of my tips
motifs of profiles profile of motives
until our motive keep improving so this
is the key idea of the algorithm demise
massive search we simply iterate and see
whether the score of motif continues to
improve and stop when it doesn't improve
anymore the only question about this
algorithm
how in the world it can find anything
useful
think about this we started from
completely random motives if they are
completely random then presumably and if
they're taken from random sequences then
presumably expected probability of every
element in profile matrix is 1 over 4
there is absolutely no information in
such a massive how possibly it can lead
us to the correct match even the signal
let's just keep our fingers crossed and
see how this approach works on an
example here's my example this is a very
short DNA strings and I implanted
for one might even each strength it's
shown in blue so a CGT is implanted in
every sequence movies a single mutation
so how randomized motif search will
proceed first it will randomly select
matías shown in bold here and as you see
of course it means most of the matías
they're randomly selected afterwards it
will form my Tiff's matrix shown here on
the slide and afterwards it will
construct profile of Matthews using
profile of Matthias it will calculate
probability of every k-mers in the set
of strengths shown here and simply
select the most probable k-mers in every
strength the results are in this matrix
and I should probably start iterative
but if you look carefully at this matrix
I don't have to iterate it already found
all blue inserted motifs right there it
almost sounds like a magic trick because
we started from something completely
random and in a single iteration found
our implanted motifs what happened so
let's try to think about this when we
form
k-mers randomly it results in a uniform
expected profile as we discussed before
but strings in DNA are not random
because we have inserted implanted
patterns in the in our DNA and therefore
this implanted mighty result in a biased
profile it's not completely random
profile where does the statistical bias
points to if it points to direction of
the implanted motifs then there is no
miracle that we start from something
random which is not really random and
applying iterative procedure
arrived to a hidden partner so let's see
how how it actually works
so I returned back to the case that we
considered before and you saw that when
we randomly selected my tears in the
first sequence we means the material the
correct the blue one in the second we
also missed in the shot we missed it in
the force minister by in the fifth one
simply by pure chance they actually
found it's not a big deal just ranvir's
resolve these probabilities that we
simply by chance select one of the
correct length of the implanted motifs
but it results in the bias profile if
you look at the profiles that resulted
from this implantation then you see the
largest element in this profile actually
corresponds to AC GMT of our implanted
pattern acidity therefore even a single
correctly found Kaymer in the set of DNA
strings create biasing the profile and
this bias leads us to the correct
sequence of course it doesn't always
happens it depends on how we have chosen
initial set of randomly selected cameras
in the signals but if we try this
algorithm thousand or million times
there is a good chance that eventually
one of these attempts will bring us to
the correct motive even if this
procedure sounds completely read across
and we now move to the next topic which
is how do bacteria hibernate to try to
apply our mattias find in calgary to
real biological problems to figure out
how our algorithm work on real
biological data we will start by
analyzing tuberculosis tuberculosis is a
deadly disease that killed quarter of
population in Europe in the 19th century
unfortunately Humanity is not done
to use tuberculosis since tuberculosis
strength strains that resists to all
antibiotics are now imagined and
tuberculosis is caused by Mycobacterium
tuberculosis also called
MTB an interesting things about MTB is
that it can persist in the for decades
in human and one third of the world
population is affected by MTB of course
it usually doesn't lead to tuberculosis
but in some cases it bacteria switches
from its latent States to active States
and then it went to calculus
this is begins the questions that we
will be asking is how MTB switches from
latent to active States and how does it
survive during latency MTB has an
ability to form dormant strong spores
where metabolism is shut down and in
such poor elated form it can survive in
very tough conditions for example in
conditions of food shortage or
oxygens for shortage and oxygen shortage
called
hypoxia is associated with latent forms
of tuberculosis so how can we figure out
what makes MTB switch into latent latent
States and return back into the active
States what biologists done they
performed a DNA experiment and identify
roughly 25 genes that are activated in
the hypoxic condition so when bacteria
is deprived from oxygen this gen
dramatically changed the expression and
our goal today is to discover what
regulatory motif controls these genes
when they're activated or repressed we
now have quite an arsenal of outlets for
finding materials let's try them but the
first problem we have
is we have no clue of what size of my
teeth to try
should we try K equal eight or k equal
Tony let's try all of them using median
strain problem and randomized massive
search and you will see that for
different K they get in quite different
results
it is not clear which one to choose for
median string we actually will have
difficulties going beyond k equal 12
because remember it is an exponential
algorithm whose running time grows as 4
to the power K but for randomized
massive search we can search for very
long motive and for K equals money we
actually find this rather long motive
and you can see that there are
similarities between 12 male found by
median strength 12 male found by
randomized motif search and 20 male
found by randomized motif search which
one is correct to answer this question
we need to introduce the notion of the
motif entropy and entropy of material is
defined in the following way
first we construct the profile matrix
every comb of profile matrix correspond
to a bias four-sided dice or in other
words to a probability distribution P 1
P 2 P n sum of t is equal to 1 of course
an entropy is simply defined as minus P
I multiplied by negative P I and sum up
over all probabilities for example we
can compute the entropy of the first
column and it will be 1 point 1 4 7 and
we can compare it with the minimal
possible entropy which corresponds to
the motif extremely conservative where
all symbols in the column are the same
and this maximal entropy where every
symbol in the column is equally likely
so the entropy of a might've is the
fine is the sum of the entropies of its
coal and now the moment of truth let's
see how the algorithm find out whether
the mighty that we find are close to the
biological one he is might've logger of
the dormancy survival regulator side and
massive log is constructed in such a way
that the total length of four
nucleotides in the motovlogger
correspond to true - entropy so four
completely conserved column like
nucleotide G in this mighty we will have
height - it is a shows the most
conservative ends of the motif the
relative sizes of force nucleotide of
four nucleotide in each position
correspond to frequencies of these
nucleotides in the core so now this is
an example of motovlogger now let's see
how it works for tuberculosis example
you can see that our randomized motif
search actually captured a good portion
of material but you can also see that we
missed in some places and we need to
work harder and to figure out what to do
to develop better regulatory matter
finding algorithm we move next to
another randomized algorithms sampling